now the first phase by russian standards
was supposed to be all over by the 8th
of march and this is a map
as the situation looked on the 8th of
march and the russians were supposed to
seize kiev in the first 24
36 hours within three days and then
conduct mopping up operations where
there was any sort of discussion or
about the issue
elsewhere by the 8th of march and they
didn't do it i mean they they had elite
forces their their elite force the first
gods tank army the the second combined
arms army
working from sumi up there in the
northeast they were supposed to be in
kiev within hours and they didn't make
it after several weeks um down in the
south they did a little bit better but
even there they used their airborne
troops their elite troops not one of
their elite units seized their
objectives and held on to them so they
lost everywhere the first phase was a
complete disaster okay so when that all
failed what did they then try next phase
two um and so they tried to turn it from
a sort of a an attempt to grab the
government in kiev to a a maneuverous
approach so they then tried um by the
21st of march we've selected this map
because it's about the way it was in the
middle of this phase the middle phase
where they were surrounding cities
chernihev and sumi and kharkiv and mario
paul of course they'd seized cursion in
the south because the the campaign from
crimea was the most efficient part of
the campaign better units uh shorter
lines of communication better
preparation in general easier job for
them but elsewhere there were
surrounding cities that they couldn't
take and they had not enough troops and
not the right equipment to really fight
their way into the cities and they
weren't inclined to do it so the second
phase was this attempt to maneuver
maneuvers approach to actually subdue
the whole country and still surround
kiev which by the 21st of march they had
signally failed to do
and so they decided well we'll we'll
think of a new strategy again so phase
three of the war was a different
strategy again and that was well their
objective stated objective was to focus
on donbass exactly so they said well
what we always intended to do all of
this was just preparation what we always
intended to do was to protect the
russian minorities in the donbass region
in luhansk and don yet
and so they rediverted the troops that
have been beaten in kiev and quite badly
beaten were rediverted around the
outside of the clock in russia to come
into this new offensive in the in the
donbass region they wanted to
strengthen their whole uncursion in the
south make sure they didn't lose any
more in the south because they'd already
been being pushed back from mikalayev
and so this is a an attempt to as it
were grab the the territory that they
that they always said mattered to them
from the very beginning okay so day61
where are are they are we
in that key donbass region yeah so as of
today they're trying to draw this famous
line that i keep talking about between
kharkiv and mario paul to create this
salient and catch most of the uh the uh
ukrainian army who are dug in there on
the wrong side of the salient to
literally uh surround them in reality
they're trying to push from uh isiam
which is a bit further this way down to
donetsk that would be a smaller version
of the salient that's as much as they
can do at the moment and they're not
making very much progress they are
making more progress at cursion they're
pushing hard at cursion again this week
and there are a lot of rumors that they
intend maybe even on may the first to
hold a referendum incursion which of
course would show by some 90 majority
despite whatever what really happens
would would aim to show that people want
to join the russian federation as they
said they did in luhansk and don yes so
that's where we are for now this offense
is not going terribly well something
important may be happening around
kirshen this week okay we shall see
professor clark thank you very much